da gestern habe ich es erst wieder auf
whatsapp gelesen viele von euch haben
angst vor einem atomunfall im belgischen
atomkraftwerk djs ist wegen zahlreicher
störfälle regelmäßig in den schlagzeilen
und tatsächlich risikoanalysen zeigen im
worst case würde die radioaktivität in
richtung deutschland verbreitet die
städteregion aachen würde bei einem
reaktorunglück unbewohnbar und auch das
ruhrgebiet köln und düsseldorf wurden
verstrahlt also was würde ein unfall im
atomkraftwerk teams bedeuten
gibt es möglichkeiten sich vor der
gefährlichen radioaktivität zu schützen
und was muss noch passieren damit sich
belgien von der atomkraft verabschiedet
jetzt in klicks und salz entwickeln
herzlich willkommen
nicht nur die meisten expertinnen und
auch politiker innenbehörden städte und
gemeinden sehen das belgische
atomkraftwerke als großes risiko liegt
in der nähe von lüttich und ist nur etwa
70 kilometer von aachen mit seinen knapp
250.000 einwohnern entfernt düsseldorf
in köln sind etwa 130 kilometer weit weg
das ist eigentlich ein unscheinbarer
kasten mit drei druckwasser reaktoren
gebaut ende der 60er jahre der erste
block ist seit 1975 in betrieb doch die
sicherheitssysteme sind überholen immer
wieder kommt es zu grösseren störfällen
und zwar zu größeren nachdem der reaktor
für einige zeit vom netz genommen werden
muss 2002 kam es zur bislang schlimmsten
störungen ein ventil stand einige zeit
offen
der druck viel ab und das kühlwasser
verdampft das ist ziemlich schlimm eine
kernschmelze wurde durch die
sicherheitssysteme verhindert der
protest gegen teams wird immer größer
mittlerweile gibt es sogar klagen gegen
das kernkraft einzig und allein belgien
selbst hält daran fest die atomaufsicht
des landes hält die reaktorblöcke für
sicher dabei ist der druckbehälter mit
rund achtung 3200 rissen übersät wie
bitte no risk no fun oder was nur das
alles andere als fun werden es ist
einfach komplett bescheuert wie die
menschen offenen august die leben von
millionen anderer menschen in gefahr
bringen
das erinnert etwas an fukushima schlimm
die stadt aachen sorgt lieber vor als
nach werten darüber berichtet die
behörden hatten
vergangenen jahr jodtabletten verteilt
die verhindern sollen dass die
schilddrüse radioaktives jod aufnimmt
eine wirklich klasse aktion die es
bundesweit bisher nur in ausnahmefällen
und nur in sehr begrenzten regionen gab
und den nachbarn ist es sehr ernst zitat
je nachdem wie das genaue szenario
aussieht haben wir ganz große zweifel
dass wir es schaffen jodtabletten
rechtzeitig zu verteilen das sagt der
verantwortliche koordinator markus
krämer damit meint er verschiedene
faktoren die das horrorszenario
atomunfall maßgeblich beeinflussen was
passiert der unfall nachts oder tagsüber
wie ist das wetter gibt es starken wind
und regnet es und damit dem worst case
nicht auch noch schnell und in panik
ausgabestellen für jodtabletten
eingerichtet werden müssen sorgt meinen
aachen lieber vor und zwar nach der
empfehlung der strahlenschutzkommission
denn die empfiehlt für gebiete der
außenzone für den fall der freisetzung
radioaktiven jods infolge eines schweren
reaktorunfalls die verteilung von
jodtabletten die kosten für die ganze
aktion übernimmt übrigens das land
nordrhein westfalen das will schon etwas
heißen eingenommen werden sollen die
tabletten aber nicht vorsorglich sondern
erst wenn die katastrophenschutzbehörde
dazu auffordert das alles sei eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme heißt es in einer
offiziellen broschüre der stadt trotzdem
sagt das schon echt viel aus wenn die
politik und die verwaltung so eine
maßnahme für nötig hält wir haben hier
ja schon öfter über atomunfälle
berichtet doch welche fatalen
konsequenzen hätte ein unfall im
atomkraftwerk teams das liegt nämlich
ziemlich ungünstig expertinnen und
experten haben genau das in
risikoanalysen untersucht der auftrag an
das institut für sicherheits und reaktor
wissenschaften in wien kam von der
städteregion aachen selbst und die
ergebnisse sind katastrophal und
angsteinflößend zugleich in der
untersuchung analysierte das
forschungsteam vor allem tausende
wetterdaten um zu sehen in welchem
ausmaß und in welche richtung die
gefährliche radioaktive strahlung
gelangen würde fest steht falls die
hülle von france 2 birst könnte dies ein
unfall in der größenordnung von
fukushima bedeutenden das risiko ist
gegeben dazu der beteiligte
kernkraftexperte wolfgang renneberg wie
sie auf die hälfte seiner dicke ist ein
reaktor druckbehälter mit
rissen durchzogen das ist ein
sicherheitsrisiko dass man nicht dulden
kann
explosionen und feuer würden das ganze
verschlimmern und die radioaktivität
massiv erhöhen wenn solch ein unfall
passieren würde könnte es sein dass ganz
aachen unbewohnbar wurde das
forschungsteam berechnet dazu ein risiko
von 18 prozent
die radioaktive belastung der stadt sei
dann vergleichbar mit der in der 20
kilometer sperrzone um fukushima so
renneberg falls eine extrem ungünstige
wetterlage herrscht mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit erreicht die
radioaktive strahlung bei einem unfall
aber das 25 fache der belastung die ein
mensch durchschnittlich pro jahr
aushalten muss auch bei diesem wert
müsse die region evakuiert werden so
dass studien themen auch andere teile
von nordrhein-westfalen wie etwa das
ruhrgebiet mit seinen fünf millionen
einwohnern könnten der studie zufolge
verstrahlt werden ebenso wie düsseldorf
und köln am rhein
insgesamt wohnen in dieser region 10
millionen menschen hinzu kommt die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den betroffenen
ländern deutschland belgien und den
niederlanden
das ist alles andere als optimal das
haben niederländische
sicherheitsexperten und experten
festgestellt sie waren davor dass wohl
alle länder ihr eigenes ding machen
würden katastrophenpläne müssten
eigentlich besser abgestimmt werden und
bürger besser informiert werden
und als sei das nicht alles schon
tragisch genug auch finanziell
solch eine atomkatastrophe gigantische
schäden zwar gibt es fünf internationale
abkommen die die haftung in solchen
fällen übernehmen zitat das problem
dabei ist nur dass sie zu erwarteten
kosten um ein vielfaches höher sein
werden als die in den abkommen
festgelegten haftungssummen und
deckungsvorsorge summen das sagt die
wissenschaftlerin lena reuster zur
erklärung ein super gau also ein
riesiger atomunfall würde wohl kosten im
dreistelligen milliardenbereich
verursachen dreistellig die
haftungsgrenzen der betreiber liegen
daher im dreistelligen millionenbereich
die obergrenze für die die akw-betreiber
in den meisten eu staaten haften müssen
liegt unter einer milliarde in belgien
und in
erlangen sind es immerhin 1,2 milliarden
euro es gibt rechnung nach denen die
geschädigten bei einem unfall in trance
wohl nur ein prozent ihres schadens
ersetzt bekommen würden anspruch
gegenüber dem deutschen staat besteht
gar nicht klar ist jedenfalls nicht nur
die behörden sondern vor allem die
aachener bürger sind mehr als
verunsichert immer wieder mal gibt es
katastrophenübung gegen die drohende
atomare verseuchung viele halten die
verteilung der jodtabletten als noch
nicht ausreichend auch schutzkleidung
gegen den radioaktiven staub sei wichtig
diana fordern dass die orange
abgeschaltet wird denn nur das sei ein
effektiver schutz für die bevölkerung
doch bisher ohne erfolg ihr problem wird
nicht kleiner denn der atomausstieg
belgiens ist ja extrem unwahrscheinlich
eigentlich hatte man sich schon 2011
darauf verständig bis 2015 den
atomausstieg zu schaffen
doch das land ist abhängig von der
atomenergie wie kaum ein anderes land in
der eu ohne sie droht stromknappheit die
risikoanalyse aus wien jedenfalls zeigt
noch einmal deutlich dass große
sicherheitsrisiko das von t orange
ausgeht der weitere betrieb sei nun mit
solch einem seriösen nachweis dass auch
die region betroffen seid noch weniger
hinnehmbar so helmut etschenberg chef
der aachener städteregion anfang 2016
hatte die stadt region aachen geklagt
und einen sogenannten nichtigkeit am tag
vor dem staatsrat eingereicht es
richtete sich gegen das erneute
hochfahren des reaktorblocks 2
sowohl die länder nordrhein-westfalen
und rheinland-pfalz und auch über 100
kommunen aus deutschland den
niederlanden und luxemburg waren
beigetreten seit rund einem jahr wird
jetzt vor dem gericht erster instanz in
brüssel geklagt wird die stilllegung des
kernkraftwerkes 2 gefordert die
begründung die persönliche betroffenheit
im falle eines schweren atom- und falles
wenn ihr als erste neue studios und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video eben vorab und das
garantiert könnten direkt in der
redaktion vom krieg so mitmachen und mir
themen vorschlagen oder andere
vorschläge machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der
genau der glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
bereiten sich auf atomunfall vor
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran